6 Uhr morgens im Osten
Brandenburgs die Bundespolizei hat dem
Grenzgebiet die Präsenz erhöht eine der
flüchtlingsrouten verläuft über Polen
die Anordnung aus dem
Bundesinnenministerium lautet mehr
Grenzkontrollen so will man unerlaubte
Zuwanderung bekämpfen und die
schleuserindustrie trocken legen wir
können eine Migration nicht zu 100%
verhindern aber wir können es den
Schleusern und den die das ganze
organisieren so schwer und so
unattraktiv wie möglich machen Einsatz
Ende
septemberowakisches Kennzeichen vorne
saßen zwei mliche Personen als die
Polizei den Wagen auf der B12 stoppt
können Sie einen der beiden Schleuser
schnappen auf der Ladefläche 30 Männer
Frauen und Kinder Sie bitten um Asyl
alle sein aus Syrien nur einer aus dem
Irak
[Musik]
jeder vierte kommt inzwischen mit Hilfe
von Schleusern so hat die Bundespolizei
Forst allein im September
2501 Migranten bei unerlaubter Einreise
aufgegriffen immerhin auch 38 mutmaßlich
kriminelle Schleuser mehr Kontrollen
bedeuten nicht automatisch weniger
Flüchtlinge in
Deutschland Problem ist glaub ich diese
Erwartungshaltung dass die bundespol die
Leute abfängt und zurückschickt das ist
einfach rechtlich nicht
drin wir fragen den Migrationsforscher
Rü kopmanns was hält er von
Grenzkontrollen ja ganz wenig die
Politiker wollen natürlich gerne
vermitteln dass sie die Kontrolle jetzt
wiedererlangen werden in einer EU mit
offenen Grenzen gibt es keine nationale
Lösung für die Kontrolle der Zuwanderung
also es ist zum Z einem großen Teil ist
Symbolpolitik das Problem kann nur an
den Außengrenzen gelöst
werden am Grenzübergang in Zels wird das
deutlich auf der anderen Seite der
Brücke ist Polen dort drüben irgendwo
setzen Schleuser die geflüchteten ab die
anschließend zu Fuß nach Deutschland
kommen kannü jetzt das Fahrzeug anhalten
die Person
rauslassen dann laufen sie selber rüber
aber dann kriegst du auch nur die
Asylbewerber aber nicht
aber auf der brü wird außerdem auf
deutscher Seite inzwischen von Anwohnern
gemeldet überhaupt erfahren wir viele
Aufgriffe erfolgen hier gar nicht durch
Grenzkontrolle die meisten wissen wer
hier im Dorf wohnt und wenn sich dort
eine fremde Person od fremde Fahrzeuge
bewegen sind die Leute mittlerweile sehr
sensibel und rufen uns auch an ich s mal
so wenn wir sagen wir reden vielleicht
von dre vi großen Gruppen am Tag dann
ist vielleicht ein Drittel davon Z dritt
davon sind
bürgerhinweise blingen
badenwürtemberg der Landkreis muss 300
zusätzliche Flüchtlinge Unterbringen der
Gasthof im Stadteil Killer soll
Flüchtlingsunterkunft werden als der
Landrat darüber informiert wird schnell
klar was die Bürger davon
halten und Entscheidung nicht einfach
machen Ja oder Nein Ja oder Nein Ja oder
Nein in Killer ist nicht nur der Platz
inzwischen Mangelware wir haben schon
welche und die Reichen
äh die soll da bleiben wo sie herkommen
ich mE ehrliche Meinung von wir schaffen
das ist kaum noch was zu spüren ich weiß
wie viel noch mit wenn wir die
flüchtlingstrom anzieht auf der Welt no
sind Millionen unterwegs wo sollen die
Leute überall unterbringen und die
wollen ja nur herkommen und das Geld vom
Staat
das finde ich
persönlich nicht
gut in einer Flüchtlingsunterkunft will
Landrat pauli zeigen weshalb Deutschland
dringend unattraktiver werden müsse für
Migranten zu viele kämen ohne
Kriegsflüchtling zu sein so wie diese
Familie aus
Georgien vor allem kamen wir wegen
meines
sohesese we dass Deutschland eine sehr
gute Gesundheitsversorgung
hat weil Sohn Luca Autist sei hat die
ganze Familie Asyl beantragt bis darüber
entschieden ist werden sie von
Deutschland versorgt wir haben gerade
den Grund warum der die Familie da ist
ist in der Gesundheit vom Sohn gibtünd
kein Asylgrund und wenn halt Deutschland
mit seinen Anreizen ein Stück weit zu
Magnet geworden ist da sind die
Deutschen selber schuld dann sollte
schon die Bundesregierung nicht zu lange
warten bis der volksstern sich weiter
aufbäumt
233 000 Asylanträge allein in diesem
Jahr Wohnraum steht kaum noch zur
Verfügung die Forderung vieler Landräte
weniger Anreize für
[Musik]
Flüchtlinge ein Vergleich wie viel Geld
erhalten Schutzsuchende innerhalb
Europas im laufenden Asylverfahren
Deutschland zahlt mit am
meisten gibt es ein Zusammenhang
zwischen Sozialleistungen und Anzahl der
[Musik]
Asylanträge wie heißt du
denn Landräte wollen auch mehr
Sachleistung statt Bargeld zahlen das
erlaubt das Gesetz zwar schon längst
aber wird kaum umgesetzt genauso wie
eine Pflicht zu gemeinnütziger Arbeit
und deswen das hilfreich wenn wir die
Chance bieten würden dass S sich
einbringen ja aber wenn wir da nicht
anfangen dann W wir mit der Situation
wie jetzt so weiterläuft fahren wir voll
gegen die Wand die Gesellschaft macht es
nicht me länger mit Deutschland müss
auch von Dänemark lernen dort ist die
Höhe der Sozialleistung an die
Arbeitssuche geknüpft das ging auch in
Deutschland sagt Klaus ruhematzen der
dne ist Arbeitsminister in
Schleswig-Holstein die Arbeitspflicht in
Dänemark gilt aber nicht nur für
Asylbewerber sie gilt auch für alle
Dänen das ist auch ein typisch dänisches
Phänomen von jedem zu fordern du musst
Teil der Lösung sein wenn du dich aus
dem System ausmelden sagt ne ich habe
hier ein keine Lust ich möchte Hause
bleiben dann sagt in Dänemark das System
ganz klar gut dann wirst du gekürzt du
musst Teil der Lösung sein ist in
übrigen ja in Deutschland auch möglich
wird nur nicht so viel genutzt
Schönebeck in SachsenAnhalt als Teil der
Lösung hat sich Ibrahim almadini schon
lange gesehen der gelernte Maler floh
2015 aus Syrien sein Sohn maruan kam
später nach dass sie nicht sofort
arbeiten durften verstehen sie bis heute
nicht noch weniger dass Deutschland auch
nach Jahren gar keinen Druck macht jetzt
plötzlich heißt es Migranten schneller
in Arbeit
[Musik]
900000 syürer wie die almadinis hat
Deutschland inzwischen aufgenommen aber
in Arbeit sind nur
38% können Sie mir sagen wieso wieso
keine Ahnung viele Leute haben kein l
und viele Leute haben viele Kinder und
wenn sie zu Hause bleiben dann bekommt
vor im viel Geld von Jobcenter oder von
andere sie mein ihre eigenen Landsleute
würden mehr arbeiten wenn Sie weniger
Leistung natürlich ja wenn sie haben
nicht viel Geld bekommen dann muss sie
arbeiten ja zumindest die Pflicht sich
Arbeit zu suchen finden Vater und Sohn
richtig erst im Job hätten beide Deutsch
gelernt Sprachschule oder
Integrationskurse allein hätten das
nicht gebracht brauch ich ke da oder
Akus brauch ich Worte und die haben Sie
da nicht gelernt ich habe ja in der
Arbeit gelernt mit den Kollege und
mein her
Ibrahim denkt ihr an die iel dass er die
vernünftig durchstreicht Danny milde ist
Geschäftsführer Ibrahim inzwischen einer
seiner besten Männer seit vier Jahren
muss der Chef aber regelmäßig aufs Amt
und drängen dass ein Mitarbeiter weiter
bei ihm arbeiten darf denn jedes Mal
wenn der befristete Aufenthalt endet
sieht schick aus ja endet auch Ibrahims
Arbeitserlaubnis ja und dann ich musste
erst selber mit hin erst als wir dort
waren und stumk gemacht haben jetzt äh
bearbeitet ih bitte damit er hier auch
weiter arbeiten kann und hier bleiben
darf ja Ibrahim hat auch deswegen die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft beantragt Z
Jahre ist das jetzt her Bescheid vom Amt
bisher Fehlanzeige sie möchten gerne
deutscher Staatsbürger werden natürlich
ich habe bis heute sehb Jahre gearbeitet
ich habe wie ich habe alle gemacht und
bis heute habe ich keine wor keine
Ahnung
warum als frontal im Fall ibrah nach
heißt es in der Ausländerbehörde man
arbeitet dort schon am absoluten Limit
es sei Zitat eine Bearbeitung derartiger
Massen ohne Landes oder Bundeshilfe
utopisch und nicht zu
schaffen Ibrahims Einbürgerung immerhin
seit zeitnah noch in diesem Winter
realistisch er arbeitet sollte hier
bleiben natürlich muss Deutschland das
Lernen nicht ich Brandenburg im
Grenzgebiet zu Polen finden fr mal und
seine Kollegen mehrere Flüchtlinge
ausgesetzt in einem Waldstück der
Schleuser ist über alle
Berge wir komm
Deutschland allein im September hat die
Bundespolizei deutschlandweit
21366 unerlaubte einreisen festgestellt
bundesinnenministerin Feser will
zusätzlich noch stationäre
Grenzkontrollen mehr Kontrollen das
heißt auch mehr Aufgriffe aber nicht
unbedingt weniger
Asylbewerber